ville-marie est un film choral dans
lequel monica bellucci obtient la plus
importante partition elle incarne une
actrice européenne qui arrivent à
montréal pour tourner un film et du même
coup retrouvé son fils qui faisait trois
ans que ce n'était pas vrai ils sont 36
kemper l'actrice italienne qui a
travaillé avec les plus grands acteurs
et réalisateurs de l'industrie a vu dans
le scénario un défi un rôle selon elle
qu on lui aurait jamais offert il y a
quinze ans c'est un rôle cadeau pour une
comédienne parce qu'il ya tellement de
facettes exploiter et il y avait
vraiment de quoi s'amuser
m
monica bellucci elle pose sa beauté et
son élégance dans le film mais elle se
révèle aussi plus vulnérable que jamais
elle se rend compte qu'elle doit lever
sa carapace et avoir le courage d'être
une mère des tons femmes et attend des
recettes nouvelles et humanité c'est
découvrir plusieurs destins se croisent
dans ville marie se d'ambulanciers joué
par patrick hivon et louis champagne
mais aussi celui d'une infirmière
incarné par pascale bussières guy édoin
qu'un jeune cinéaste homme porte un
regard très lucide sur les femmes un peu
plus vieille qui font un bilan de vie
qui avait chargé de toutes leurs
tragédies leur histoire avec cette
sensibilité le jeune cinéaste révèle
monica bellucci comme on ne l'a jamais
vu il y avait l'idée dès le départ dans
le scénario de la désacraliser de la
magnifier et puis de l'amener un point
un tournant dans son art you ou du plu
de phares les plus de face et c'est
vraiment la femme est une actrice et une
de masse j'ai compris pourquoi excepté
le tournis si ça prend frêle accepte de
tourner sans fard sans rien donc je
savais qu'il fallait que d'un point de
vue humain qu'on construit cette
relation de ville-marie a été très bien
accueilli par les critiques lors de la
première à toronto le film poursuit
maintenant sa route vers l'italie où il
a été retenu en compétition au festival
de film de rome il prend la fiche sur
nos écrans le 9 octobre ici tanya
lapointe radio canada montréal